Upon figuring out her shoe was untied, Lauren sought social support from her
friends and family. Often times we talk to our friends and family when we're
experiencing stressful events and it can help relieve some of the negative
emotional responses that we have. A second type of coping strategy is the one
that we see Lauren doing. And this is called emotion focus coping. One form of
that is seeking social support. With emotion focus coping we try to reduce the
emotional distress that we're experiencing. Now psychologists have come up with
at least six different ways in which we can use emotion focus coping, as tools
to reduce our stress. In addition to seeking social support, another
emotion-focused coping tool is distancing.